American culture is very ambiguous we
don't have a defined cultural identity
that people theoretically could
assimilate to so it becomes difficult to
say where any lines are and then you add
policy on top of that you don't think
America had like a broad overarching
culture I think we could and we did at
one point but I think as it stands right
now Americans are very resistant to
cultivating American culture I mean
think about everyone who was like if
Trump gets elected I will move to Canada
like there's all kinds of resistance to
being American if that's how our young
people feel then we have failed to
culture to maintain a cultural identity
young people in the United States a lot
of the people that I end up working with
when I'm like touring and stuff like
that younger people really don't they
want to avoid the Nationalist uh idea
and that comes or just patriotism well
that that's what they they see
patriotism as nationalism they see
American flags and they are they're
turned off by it and some people that
I'm really really close to and that that
I have a really great relationship with
they don't see a a love of country as
something that's important they think of
themselves as global